5 56 on your monday morning metro police
point out a
painful truth fatal hit and run auto
pedestrian crashes
are solvable crimes
that's what metro lieutenant greg munson
told our christian council saying
investigators start with a specific
theory
on all of our hit and runs that we've
had and we've investigated we've solved
none of those people left that day to
kill somebody that wasn't their intent
that would be a different crime
munson says drivers in these incidents
can only help themselves by stepping
forward
people have to be held accountable for
their mistakes but don't make them worse
for yourself and even if those folks
don't turn themselves in their own
behavior
often gives them away somebody knows
who did it somebody knows a friend a
brother says somebody knows
if somebody comes to you and tells you
that hey i just hit somebody i think
you should absolutely step up and say
you need to go and turn yourself in you
need to call the police right now
if the community is willing to help us
with this we can we could we could close
all these
every one of these unsolved hitting runs
that we have right now somebody knows
about it
pretty strong stuff the road to closure
in unsolved cases starts with people
doing the right thing buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone if
there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8
8newsnow.com